I want to start with a poem,
play the audio of it for you.
You should listen--you
should be able to hear it
pretty--pretty well. The
poem is called Old Lem
by a man named Sterling Brown,
one of the great poets in
American letters in the
twentieth century. He
writes the poem
after--you know,
we're talking this week
about the first decade and a
half or so of the twentieth
century. This poem was
written after that,
written I think in the
nineteen--late twenties or
early thirties. I don't
remember off the top of my
head. But it speaks to the
experiences, the rural
experiences and the social
and political experiences
of African Americans.
And it certainly is, as
you'll hear in the poem,
it gives you sort of a
context behind why people
might not want to
stay in the South.
The poem is
called--called Old Lem.
Old Lem - "I talked to
old Lem and old Lem said:
They weigh the cotton
They store the corn
We only good enough
To work the rows;
They run the commissary
They keep the books, We gotta be
grateful,  For being cheated;
Whippersnapper clerks
Call us out of our name, We got
to say mister, To spindling boys
They make our figgers,
Turn somersets,
We buck in the middle,
Say, 'Thankyuh, sah.'
They don't come by ones,
They don't come by twos
But they come by tens.
They got the judges,
They got the lawyers
They got the jury-rolls
They got the law
They don't come by ones
They got the sheriffs
They got the deputies
They don't come by twos
They got the shotguns
They got the rope
We git the justice in the end
And they come by tens.
Their fists stay closed
Their eyes look straight
Our hands stay open
Our eyes must fall
They don't come by ones
They got the manhood
They got the courage
They don't come by twos
We got to slink around
Hangtailed hounds.
They burn us when we dogs
They burn us when we men
They come by tens...
I had a buddy
Six foot of man
Muscled up perfect
Game to the heart
They don't come by ones
Outworked and outfought
Any man or two men
They don't come by twos
He spoke out of turn
At the commissary
They gave him a day
To git out the county
He didn't take it.
He said 'Come and get me.'
They came and got him
And they came by tens.
He stayed in the county--
He lays there dead.
They don't come by ones
They don't come by twos
But they come by tens."
Again, that's
Sterling Brown,
poem named Old Lem, talking
about forms of southern
justice. If you dare to
speak back to somebody,
if you're black and spoke
back to somebody who was
white, they might come after
you. They would not come by
ones or twos; they'd come by
tens. What I want to talk
about today, having set that
really uplifting context for
the day's lecture, is talk
about the Great Migration
and take us forward into the
1910s with the film called
The Birth of a Nation.
Essentially what I want to
do in today's lecture is
look at the beginning of a
fundamental shift in
demographics of black
America in--as far as
geography's concerned.
Black America is still
overwhelmingly a rural
population, and is
overwhelming--overwhelmingly
southern. That begins to
change and change rather
quickly during the Great
Migration. Now I ended last
week's lecture talking about
the founding of the NAACP,
1909. And I
want to point out,
the NAACP is not--was
not the only organization
founded at that--at this
time that focused on the
quality of black life.
Another such organization
was the Young Men's
Christian Association,
and the Young Women's
Christian Association. Both
groups are
highly segregated,
but they still played in--a
central role in making space
available for
blacks, particularly black
travelers.
Housing was provided,
hot meals would be provided,
community organizing. These
become sites of
community organizing,
much like black
churches were playing,
still to this day of course,
but before that. In fact,
with the YMCA, I was on
an internship right after
college and the internship
leader--this is 1989,
1990--the internship leader
was talking about when he
was coming through L.A.
in the 1960s, traveling
there for the first time,
every black man knew that he
had to go to the YMCA if he
wanted to find a place to
stay. So this is not just
the history of 1900s and the
1910s and teens. It goes
forward all the way
and through really the
systematic
desegregation of society,
or at least sort of
structurally in the 1960s
and seventies. Anyway,
aside from the NAACP,
and in addition to the Young
Men's and Young Women's
Christian Associations,
you have one of the most
important betterment
organizations being founded
in this area, and that's
the National Urban League,
founded in 1911. Now
whereas the NAACP dedicated
itself to a legal and
intellectual strategy,
trying to find ways to
seek justice for African
Americans through legal
means and through the idea
of sort of civilizing,
uplifting society,
through the Talented
Tenth, the Urban League was
explicitly
concerned with labor,
finding jobs for blacks,
sometimes at any cost. The
Urban League was chiefly
concerned with finding jobs
for blacks who were newly
arrived to urban northern
centers. The
Urban League was,
from the start, less radical
than the NAACP. Now to even
think of the phrase NAACP
and radical going together
may sound strange, but it
really was sort of an avant
garde organization in many
ways at its founding. Urban
League wasn't in that
regard. Some will claim,
as you'll see later on, that
the Urban League was really
quite the opposite, a
conservative force in the
back pocket of
corporate interests,
and willing to bust unions
in order to put blacks into
jobs of any kind. Now the
issue of jobs here can't be
overemphasized. Jobs are
important in any era to any
people, of course, but when
you have a large segment of
the population, of a
socially identified
population, black
folks in this case,
in great flux, jobs become
that much more critical.
Blacks were that
population. They were in
profound flux in the first
decades of the twentieth
century, and it is
their mass migration,
what is referred to in this
era as the Great Migration,
and the events
that surround that,
that form the basis of this
week's lectures. Now I want
to start with just a
clarification of the title,
the name of this phenomenon,
the Great Migration. At
this moment in time, roughly
early years of the twentieth
century to roughly the
start of World War I,
this was the greatest
internal migration of a
people in U.S.
history. However, and we'll
get to it in a couple of
weeks, the migration of
African Americans in the
1940s and early fifties way
outstrips the migration I'm
talking about now but
the--in terms of number.
But the naming is--the
naming convention is such
that this early period of
migration is called the
Great Migration, just to be
clear about that fact. Now
aside from
naming conventions,
I want you to also realize
that when I think of the
Great Migration, I think
of--I think that it needs to
be understood as a
political movement,
that migration itself was
a political act. Was it
organized in the ways that
we think of in terms of high
politics or even grassroots
protest movements? No,
it wasn't. It wasn't. But
it was profoundly political
and I wanted to delineate
those reasons over the next
little bit.
It's important to
first start to look at the
southern black situation at
the turn of the century.
That's why I played
that clip for you,
to get a, sort of a
sense, at least artistically
rendered, of the stakes, of
the narrow room within which
African Americans could
move and move safely in the
South. Blacks who had the
option of staying in the
South left during the Great
Migration because all the
political privileges that
they had enjoyed during
Reconstruction had been
systematically stripped
away. And I've been talking
about this the last couple
of weeks. Blacks who had
the resources to leave,
and that's a big issue, if
they had the actual means to
get out of town, they might
have left just for the fact
that, you know, any hope of
their having the right to
vote and all the other
political benefits that come
along with that just
weren't in the mix any more,
not after Redemption,
not after the systematic
stripping away of the black
voting presence. The men
couldn't vote any longer.
State funded education for
blacks was functionally
nonexistent. Social
segregation was only
increasing and there of
course was always the
looming threat of lynch
law. So lacking even the
most basic political rights,
some blacks just up and
left. Black farmers might
have left simply because of
the sharecropping system,
something else alluded to
in this poem by Sterling
Brown. Sharecropping,
as you already know,
a form of employment that
looked all too much like
slavery. It was a dead
end. Better opportunities,
the bedrock of any sort
of political philosophy,
awaited black
sharecroppers in the north;
at least, this was the
thinking. So you have the
combination of,
maybe a little dramatic,
political death in the South
as an option. That's not
very viable, so blacks might
want to leave. An economic
system that's determined to
keep them in second-class
citizenship status. So we
think of--of the forces in
the South that,
or the reality,
the daily lived reality on
the ground in the South,
you can see that just the
determination to leave,
to get out, was a response
to the political and
economic
situation. And in that way,
the decision, I think,
is--can be rendered as sort
of a political decision.
And it's interesting if you
think about it,
sticking on this issue of,
you know, the
politics of the situation,
it's interesting to
think about how whites
reacted--southern whites
reacted to black exodus. At
first, in some
reg--in some regions,
whites were thrilled.
"We can finally get the
so-called negro
problem"--this was a popular
phrase of the age--"the
negro problem would leave
once blacks left town."
But rather quickly they
realized, "Wait a second.
This is our bedrock labor
force. This is the force
that keeps whites--poor
whites placated, because at
least they're not black."
The social order was based
on color caste and it was
being destroyed by black
ex--exodus. So whites begin
to threaten blacks if
they make plans to leave.
It sounds
completely nonsensical,
but this is just the state
of the case. And there were
white northerners coming
down who were labor agents,
and white municipalities
start charging these labor
agencies--I'll explain
more about them in a
second--exorbitant fees
to register to try to get
blacks out.
It doesn't matter. Labor
agents have the resource.
Southern whites
started seeing their
socio--socioeconomic
political system,
the foundation upon which
so much of it was built,
starting to crumble
with black exodus. Now
historians talk about push,
when it comes to the Great
Migration, push-pull
factors. There's debate
whether that's a useful
model or not. I'm not going
to worry about,
sort of, that debate,
but I am going to talk
about a series of different
factors that were at play,
that really combine in such
a way that make this
migration so powerful,
so large. You
have an infestation,
is one of the ways that
makes this migration so
important, the boll weevil.
A little pest that comes up
from Mexico, sweeps across
Texas and into southeastern
U.S. The boll weevil is a
little bug that gets into
the boll.
cotton boll, B-O-L-L, and
destroys it. Cotton wasn't
the only crop in the South,
but it was the main crop.
It was so much of the
bedrock of the southern
economy was in that
agricultural product.
Cotton crops get destroyed.
There's no work for blacks.
They're working the farms.
If you can't find work,
what's the point of staying
around? I already mentioned
political disfranchisement.
This job scarcity in the
South is also an
economic--and the South is
essentially an economic
colony of the North,
and then the North has
a decreasing supply of
immigrant labor, as you move
forward into the twentieth
century, as a result of
state conflict in European
theaters, heading towards
World War I. Just take
these things together,
there's a decreasing reason
to stay in the South and the
lure of jobs in the North.
Assisting this, or abetting
this process even more,
are the individuals
I mentioned before,
labor agents. These are
essentially job recruiters
employed by people who
own factories and mills,
mines in the
Midwest and the North,
who would travel South,
since the labor supply was
drying up in the North and
come into a town--and I'm
making up the numbers
here--come into a town where
there's a, you know, a lot
of blacks looking for work
and say, "Look, in the North
you can own your own house
or an
apartment. You can vote,
sit where you want to on the
bus. We've got a job here.
The job's going to pay
you three dollars a day,
unheard of amounts of
money. Being able to own
property or at least rent
property where you want to
and ride on the bus,
sit where you want to,
unheard of possibilities in
the South. And they go well
we--They said, "Well, we
can't afford the train fare
to get up to, say Chicago or
Cincinnati or Cleveland."
He says, "Don't worry
about it. I'll pay for it,
and you can
work it off." Or,
"Don't even worry about it.
I'll just pay for it." So
labor agents are coming down
and signing up a black labor
force to come to
work in the mines,
and factories, and
mills. You have,
of course, informal
lines of communication,
people who make, you know
that first person to make
the trip up to
Chicago and saying,
"My god, I am making
three dollars a day,
and I have my
own apartment,
and writing letters back,
or saving up a lot of money
and driving down, you know,
at the end of the year in
their own car, dressed in
their fanciest clothes.
Talk about the,
sort of the quote,
"land of milk and honey"
up North. This certainly
inspired others to travel.
And then you have a very
important newspaper,
the Chicago Defender,
the most important black
newspaper of the time.
Chicago Defender, of
course based in Chicago,
but circulated heavily
throughout the South. Bags
of the Chicago Defender
would be bundled up,
thrown on trains, and
they would appear in say
Montgomery or
Huntsville or, you know,
other southern towns. And
they'd be read by who knows
how many people. Now the
Defender made it almost a
sport talking about
lynchings happening in the
South. Most often they were
about true events. It was
an--this was an era of
newspapers where you just,
you know, made stuff up
still. So most often
talking about true events
in the South and horrible
events. And there'd be
letters to the editor,
sometimes true,
often fabricated,
but still they were
there, written by blacks,
written in dialect,
but talking about the
opportunities in the North
and--and reminding folks of
the degradation
in the South.
Chicago Defender's
incredibly important as a
tool to help people
find the courage,
or find the resources, or
the determination to move
north. And then you
have service organizations,
like the
National Urban League,
founded in 1911, dedicated
to improving the quality of
life or life chances for
blacks migrating North. So
you have, just in
the first two decades,
sort of an astonishing
convergence of all these
different forces that really
help fuel this migration.
And the numbers are
really quite striking. Just
between--this is just to get
a sense of things. You're
not going to have to know
this for the--for the like
an exam or anything.
But looking at a few major
northern cities, between
1910 and 1920--it's so funny
when I say you don't have
to know this for the exam,
the tapping stops.
That's hysterical. Anyway,
you take New
York City, in 1910,
the population--the African
American population is
around ninety
thousand. Within ten years,
it's one hundred
and fifty thousand,
an increase of sixty-six
percent. In Chicago,
the population increases by
one hundred and--almost one
hundred and fifty percent
from forty-four thousand to
one hundred and ten
thousand. In Cleveland,
population soars from eight
thousand to thirty-four
thousand, an increase of
three hundred percent. And
in Detroit, the population
goes from five thousand to
forty thousand,
population--an increase of
six hundred percent. So
radical changes in just a
ten-year period of time.
This is the era when Harlem
becomes known as a
black enclave. Now,
so we know what was getting
people out of the South.
What did they find when they
got to the North? Yeah,
they could have
their own apartments,
certainly. Owning homes
would take a little while
for most migrants, but
they would find segregated
housing, de
facto. Not de jure,
de facto. And segregated
housing was bad housing,
low quality,
poorly maintained,
sites of high
levels of crime,
vice, public health
hazards. Anybody know
Washington, D.C., that well,
sort of the area? Well
Georgetown used
to be, you know,
a sort of slum
in--in the docks,
but getting around say
Dupont Circle and heading
that area, a lot of
townhouses around there,
row houses. And
where I'm talking about,
you would go behind the row
houses to the interior of
the block and these
alley dwellings. I mean
pestilence, horrible
sights, horrible locations.
This is where a lot of
migrant blacks lived in the
alleys in Washington, D.C.,
sort of the invisible to the
public, but certainly
there. Migrants to the
North would find
native black resistance,
people who'd been there
already for generations who
thought these black
migrants talked funny,
dressed strangely, cooked
food that smelled wrong,
and were loud and boisterous
and acted out in public.
All these kind of racially
coded things we certainly
still live with, but
you have long-term black
communities deeply unhappy
about these migrants coming
up. You'd have people who
had migrated just ten years
earlier unhappy
about the new migrants,
because "they're just
making--they're embarrassing
us, they're
making increasing job
competition." Coming
up was--was filled with
challenges. You
would also have,
you know, an Urban League
trying to find people jobs.
You would have African
Americans being brought up
to a factory
where a labor union,
which blacks
weren't allowed to join,
and the union
being on strike,
and the Urban League working
with the company that owns
the factory saying--the
factory owner saying,
"Look, if you can get me one
hundred black men to work in
the factory, that would
be great. I'll give them
jobs." Well, they're
hired as scab labor,
so they are vilified by
white labor workers. It's a
job, certainly, as long as
the labor union stays on
strike. But it's a job at
some pretty serious costs,
as we'll see in this week's
readings and in Wednesday's
lecture. So life wasn't
easy and you have to think
about this tension
between, sort of,
black autonomy, the real
power in being able to make
a decision to leave town.
You can't discount that.
That's important; sort of
life changing in a sense,
just to get up and go. You
have to weigh that against
the reality of like
life when you got to your
destination might be pretty
horrible as well. Certainly
different than anything
you expected. Yeah,
you got paid more, yeah, you
had your own roof over your
head, but the tenements in
which blacks were living
were just, I mean,
horrible. I mean the stuff
beyond your imagination
in so many ways. Sure,
you could ride where
you wanted to on the bus,
but there are still costs
or risks involved in acting
out, shall we say. Again,
we'll see more of this in
the next lect--in the next
lecture. Now one thing I--I
also want to make clear
before moving into the next
phase of the lecture
is thinking about,
as we're trying to unpack
what migration really was,
it's important to realize
that migration wasn't just
blacks working on
the southern farms,
all of a sudden, you
know, in a week's time,
they're working in a
mill in Chicago. No,
it wasn't that. I
mean migration was,
among many things, at
least--I mean it was at
least very complicated. So
you might have some working
in the farm. The
boll weevil attacks;
there's no more opportunity
to work. You'd--you'd go to
the city, a southern
city, trying to find a job,
something. Cities became
crowded. This is where
labor agents would
really st--quote,
"steal."
You would find a
lot of people,
hire them up to the North.
But would they always go all
the--all, quote, "all the
way" to north to Chicago or
New York City? No, they
wouldn't. They might end up
in the coalfields
in West Virginia,
or in Ohio, or in Kentucky.
And they might work there
for, you know, six months
and then go back home to
Montgomery, just pick a
place. And then they might
leave the next year for
three months and then come
back. Migration was not
literally from field to
factory in one straight
direction. People were
going back and forth often.
They might get up to,
you know, the mines--the
coalmines in Kentucky,
be there for a couple years
and then make it to Chicago
after that, and who knows
how long they would stay?
So you need to understand
that--that--that migration
is doing--moving in many
different directions at
once, although it was
generally from field to
generally to factory. One
thing that's not ambiguous
at all during this
era is what I'll say,
the commerce of
racism. Remember,
whites didn't want to
have blacks leave--or whites
wanted blacks to
leave at first,
then realized, "Wait, this
would mess up our system,
then don't want blacks
to leave at all. Yet they
still treat blacks pretty
shabbily in their southern
towns and in their southern
fields. One thing that is
incumbent upon this sort
of commerce of racism is
control. Who's in control
of society? It's a word
I've used before. And
society becomes destabilized
by blacks moving on their
own or with the help of
labor agents, you start
seeing a real rise in white
resistance to the challenge
to this system. White
resistance to black autonomy
becomes palpable. I already
mentioned southern
resistance to labor agents
coming down. It's important
to understand there are
other things that were
developing within white
America--white southern
America that complicated the
nature of black-white
relations in the South,
and that--the most
important force is the Klan,
the KKK. Now the
Klan, you'll remember,
was destroyed at the
national level during
Reconstruction. It
starts to creep back during
Redemption, but
it's really, you know,
as terrible--terrifying
as it is,
something happens when you
get to around the height of
the migration, around 1915.
The popularity of the Klan
skyrockets, I mean
skyrockets. The fact that
it's happening at the same
time blacks are trying to
leave the South,
in a real outflow,
is no coincidence. There's
no doubt also that a large
part of the
Klan's popularity,
reborn
popularity, is a film,
D.
W.
Griffith's film called The
Birth of a Nation. This
movie is based on a
novel by a guy named Thomas
Dixon--Dixon, a novel called
The Clansman. The book as
well as the movie, and I'll
only be talking about the
movie, is a
depiction of Reconstruction,
but from a point of
view that was entirely
sympathetic to the
southern community,
southern mentality.
The film was immediately
controversial.
It was explicitly racist,
but there's no denying the
fact that it
was cinematically
revolutionary. Let's cast
inside the subject matter
for a moment. It may be
the most important film,
most important
American film of all time,
for the way it changed
what was possible from a
technical point of view. We
have large outdoor scenes,
the tracking shot,
cat's eye lenses,
fade-ins, color, or
more like tinting,
but still color,
night photography,
panning, close ups,
high angle shots,
and so forth. It was also
the first feature-length
film in American
motion picture history.
So technically, it's an
astonishing accomplishment.
When it's shown at
the White House,
Woodrow Wilson, southern
Democrat but also a scholar
of some merit,
declared that it was,
quote, "history written in
lightning." He lauded it
for its bold and accurate
depiction of the past. Now
for the record, its only
accuracy came in the fact
that it represented a type
of hysterical psychology
that captivated southerners
who felt that they were
victims of a war of northern
aggression. So Woodrow
Wilson
celebrates this thing,
this is, you know, this is
an incredible historical
document. It is an
incredible historical
document, but not for what
it shows on this--not for
the story it tells, but for
how it captures a mentality
in the nineteen-teens, and
how it excites a populist,
I guess, I guess a populist
base in white America and
helps elevate membership
numbers in the Klan. I mean
the film is hailed--and
speaking of two sides,
from the
technical standpoint,
Spike Lee, ever the
controversial artist,
talked about it as the most
important film that he's
ever--I mean it was so--the
most important film for
him. On the
other side of it,
in terms of, you know, what
the film was really about,
it's still used by the Klan
today as a recruiting tool.
So it's not just this
interesting silent movie
from the 1910s. It's still
being used today. Now the
basic storyline tracks the
rise and fall of the South,
as told through the
experiences of two different
families. You have a family
called the Stoneman-- the
Stoneman family
from the North,
and the Cameron family
from the South. So lifelong
friends, both very
powerful families,
but divided by the
Mason-Dixon line. A little
bit of Romeo and
Juliet to the story,
in that the different
sets of Stoneman and Cameron
children are in love with
each other. So the love
crosses the--the Northern
and South divide. And so
the Stonemans and Camerons
stand in as metaphors for
the entire North-South
division. These are
divisions that--these are
parts of the country that
should love each other.
They are in one spirit in
some way, but there's a
fundamental rupture and we
need to solve that rupture.
So the premise is that the
Camerons, these
are the southerners,
give three sons to the
war. Only one survives,
a guy named Ben, who
then avows--vows to avenge
southern dishonor, but he
also happens to fall in love
with--this makes it
complicated--one of the
Stoneman daughters, northern
daughter. So the sole
surviving southern male of
the Cameron clan falls in
love with the Stonemans'
daughter. On the northern
side, the Stonemans
lose one son to the war,
and the other son remains in
love with the Cameron girl,
so you see this
crossing. After the war,
Austin Stoneman, the family
patriarch and member of
Congress, comes down South
and puts the power hungry
and corrupt Silas
Lynch--that's his name.
It's not a subtle film
in any stretch of the
imagination--Silas Lynch
happens to be of mixed race,
but has a particular craving
for white women. He puts
Silas Lynch in charge of
the liberated slaves in the
Camerons' home
town of Piedmont,
and the Piedmont blacks, now
having the right to vote,
raise all sorts of trouble
for the local whites,
and especially
affected were the Camerons,
these southerners. The
film tracks this history,
the rise of
Reconstruction governments,
run by unprepared and
unqualified blacks. It
depicts blacks' social and
political intransigence and
the systematic
disenfranchisement of
southern whites. And Birth
of a Nation also gives us a
cautionary tale of what
happens when black men are
freed and find themselves
around white women. We'll
see this most clearly
in the actions of Gus,
a properly mannered servant
for the Camerons prior to
emancipation, who becomes
a leering threat with the
conclusion of the Civil
War. Despite Ben Stoneman,
the surviving young man in
the southern family in the
Civil War--despite Ben
Stoneman's warnings to Gus
to leave his family alone
and despite Ben's warning to
his younger sister Flora to
stay in the house and thus
remain safe, tragedy
strikes. Gus stalks Flora
when she leaves the home to
get water from a stream in
the woods. Flora sees Gus
stalking her and runs for
her life, knowing--and this
is all very clearly implied
in the film--that
if Gus caught her,
she would be raped. Flora
finds herself at a cliff's
edge, while
calling for help,
as Gus--Gus inches closer.
She avoids certain rape by
leaping to her death. She
dies in her brother's arms,
and Ben, already determined
to restore the South's
honor, goes after Gus. It
will come to no surprise to
you, I think, that Gus is
lynched. The castration
scenes in the film were
actually cut in the final
print. And Ben, already
inspired about how to create
a gang of southerners to
avenge the South's honor,
organizes the Klan in an--in
an explicit move to social
control, the protection of
white womanhood and--and the
Redemption of the South.
Now the story isn't just
about the tangled love
relationship that spans the
Civil War. It's also about
representation of blacks and
their quest for full
citizenship rights and the
real object that
defined that quest,
which was the white woman.
It's also a story about
romanticizing and justifying
the rise of the Klan,
the role in the salvation
of white womanhood and
therefore southern dignity.
Now spliced together,
I was doing--giving you all
this background so you'll
make sense of what you're
about to see. I spliced
together three different
scenes from the movie to
help you get a better
understanding of what's at
stake here. You should not
look at the movie--the film
so much for its
interpretation of the fall
and rise of the South.
That is patently false.
What's worth thinking about
is the particular
interpretation of blackness,
of dignity, of citizenship,
of intelligence,
objectification, etcetera.
How they all became an
object of fascination when
it was released. The
movie was a runaway hit,
played to sold-out audiences
around the country,
even though it charged
what was then the exorbitant
price of seventy-five cents
to two dollars a ticket to
get in.
This is the Stoneman family
coming down to the South to
recuperate from bad health,
and the Stoneman and the
Cameron children
see each other,
greet each other. And yes,
they're in black face when
they are appearing black.
That's Ben Cameron on the
right, with his love in
the middle and his sister,
the young one
who kills herself,
on the left. That's the
first clip. I don't--I
confess, I don't
know what happened.
I was playing
it this morning,
getting it ready, and
there's no sound for this.
So it's just--it's
just music playing in the
background.
Down here it says,
"an historical facsimile
at the State House of
Representatives of South
Carolina as it was in 1870,
after a photograph by the
Columbia State." Basically,
blacks are now in control
and this is what happens.
You'll see the fade in.
This has technically never
been done before. You'll
have a mix of characters
here in black face and
actually black actors. A
depiction of the morality of
black representatives,
drinking on the floor,
eating either a turkey
leg or a large chicken leg,
not knowing how to comport
themselves. You know,
these are the things
that are important to black
representatives. Whites
have to salute. There's
general chaos. They're not
properly behaved. But there
are some representatives,
and you can see them there,
sitting there quietly.
The close in shot like that,
again, brand new. Blacks
and whites in the gallery.
You start seeing here a
depiction of what the actual
desire of black
representatives happens to
be, and their reaction.
That's Silas Lynch in the
middle, and at the bottom
of the screen there for a
second you saw him. A mixed
race man that's come down to
take control of the South.
And this final clip right
here. His
sister's already died,
died in his arms. This is
Ben Cameron. He sees these
young white children playing
with the black children,
dressed up as piccaninnies
with their hair and such.
And it's hard to
see on the screen,
but their eyes get bug eyed,
and they're terrified. Like
I said, it wasn't the most
subtle of films. And so you
see your depictions
of black depravity,
of desire for white
women. You also see,
of course, the
loyal servants who are,
sort of, the Mammy figure,
the--the heavyset black
woman, again these
characters--these main
characters in black face.
You didn't see much
of it, Silas Lynch.
I pointed him out to
you, but the mixed race
individual, that's
northern--appointed by a
northern representative to
come down and take control
of the South, and he
desires white women. Gus,
the servant, who made
eyes at the Mammy figure,
is the one who
desires white women,
once he's armed as a member
of the northern militia.
The fear
embodied in this film,
the anxiety, is what I
really want you to take away
from it, and the fact that
the film was terrifically
popular.
It wasn't just popular as
a--as an organizing tool for
the Klan. It was
the top grossing film.
I mean I don't know if this
statistic is still true in
our Avatar age, and
some people actually see
connections to Avatar and
the kind of racial logic of
a film likeBirth of a
Nation. But the film,
off of seventy-five cent
and two dollar tickets,
earns over ten million
dollars in its first
release. Unbelievable
amounts of money. And it
also earned the specific
attention of the young--of
the young NAACP, which
lauded--which issued a
forty-seven page pamphlet
titled Fighting a Vicious
Film: Protest Against The
Birth of the Nation. They
would hold
rallies at the theater,
wherever the film
was being shown,
protesting its screening.
And it famously referred to
the film as "three miles of
filth." This is the state
of the--the culture at the
moment. Black Americans
in--in flux, migration
not happening in a uniform
direction or at
a uniform pace,
but happening, clearly.
Detroit's black population
blossoms by six hundred
percent in a ten-year span.
Black enclaves in places
that didn't--they just
simply weren't there before
are now there. So the
reorganizing, repopulating
of black America is
beginning here and continues
in earnest until around the
1970s when the--when the
population numbers begin to
settle--settle down, the
migration--migration numbers
settle down.
And actually, we're in an
age where the migration is
reversing for the first time
since this--since the start
of the twentieth century.
We're not exactly sure why
yet as far as demographers.
We're dealing with a radical
shift of population and,
and related to that, a
radical rise in social
anxieties and a
determination to control
it. And we'll see how that
control is manifested beyond
the Klan and Birth of a
Nation on Wednesday's
lecture. Thank you.